SARAH ANNESE: Thank you
everybody for having us.
This is one of the coolest
things we've ever done.
As Thomas, said
I'm Sarah Annese.
This is Giancarlo Annese.
We are married, not brother and
sister-- common misconception.
So we wrote "Beer
Lover's New York."
We're super excited to be here.
Thank you guys for
having us, and we're
excited to try some
home brews later.
So it's really awesome.
Last May we were up
in Glens Falls, which
is kind of like northern
New York in the Adirondacks.
And we were visiting this
little brewery called Davidson
Brothers, and it was, you
know, like a little brew pub.
And we're talking to the
founder, Rick Davidson,
and there's a lull
in conversation
and he kind of turns to me and
goes, what size are your feet?
So next thing I know I'm inside
the brewing kettle-- cleaning
the brewing kettle.
So then like a month
later, we find ourselves
100 feet up in the air
in a cherry picker,
in the middle of
the finger lakes
looking over at
what is soon going
to be-- which you
could see here--
a brewery called
Miles Craft Ales.
This whole experience
of writing this book
has had so many times where
we've kind of just looked
at each other and been like,
holy crap-- are we really here?
So those are just two examples
of that kind of thing.
New York State has an
incredibly rich beer history.
At one time, the state produced
90% of the country's hops.
And we have these two really
historical breweries--
Matt Brewing, which
was founded in 1888,
is still owned by
the Matt family.
And made the first beer served
after prohibition legally--
which is Utica Club.
And it's definitely iconic beer.
And then we also have Genesee,
which was founded in 1878.
And even though it's
not craft anymore,
it's still part of New
York state beer history.
Fast forward to today--
since we finished
writing the book,
which was August 5th,
30 breweries have
opened up in New York.
So it's definitely a
really exciting time
to be involved in beer
in New York state.
The laws are changing to
support this industry,
and it's really cool.
How we got this
book-- as Thomas said,
we write the website
beerunion.com.
It started as a
little blog in 2009,
and we redeveloped it
into website in 2012.
And then in April of 2013 we
just got an email, randomly,
from an editor at Globe
Pequot Press asking us
if we could write this book.
And we were just kind of
like, what, yes, of course.
So we are part of a
beer lover series.
There's beer lover's
Colorado, beer lover's Oregon,
beer lover's mid-Atlantic--
books about regional and state
beer cultures and beer guides.
So we are the New
York one, and our book
is separated by region.
It covers the best-- not
all-- but the best breweries,
brew pubs, and bars
across the whole state.
There is New York City,
Long Island, Hudson Valley,
capital region, northern New
York and the Adirondacks,
central New York and the Finger
Lakes, and Western New York.
So today we're going
to talk a little bit
about regional trends
across the state
and also highlight some
interesting and exciting
breweries going on.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: One of
the most challenging parts
about it was the four
months that we had
and the size of the state.
To do the research we
traveled over 4,000 miles
from Buffalo, Lake
Placid, Green Port.
So we were all over, and
we only had four months
to do this while holding
down full-time jobs.
So it was a lot
of long weekends,
a lot of time in the car.
We used trains, planes,
automobiles-- the whole thing.
We had our adventures
on Amtrak and such.
I mean, we were
all over the place.
And some of the trips were
kind of natural trips,
and we knew right
from when we started
that they would be dedicated
trips-- like the Adirondacks
and Lake Placid.
That's one of the first
things that we did.
Even before we signed
our book contract,
we sat down and
looked at the state--
where the breweries
were, what kind of trips
we were going to need
to make, and how many
we could jam into these trips.
Because with 135 breweries,
plus bars and home
brew shops and festivals
that we also covered,
it was a lot to fit
into four months.
We had trips to
Rochester, Buffalo, self
explanatory trips, and around
the New York City area, which
thankfully we already knew
pretty well from covering
the city on our website.
But probably the biggest
challenge was the Finger Lakes.
How many of you have been
around the Finger Lakes?
Do you guys know the
Finger Lakes at all?
There's not really
great transportation
around the Finger Lakes.
There's a lot of small roads
connecting these breweries--
not really major
highways connecting them.
You have 90 that
runs along the north,
and you have Route 17
that runs along the south.
But in the middle
there are a lot
of roads that run
north-south but not much
that runs east-west.
So it was tough to get
to all these breweries,
try to meet with the
brewers, and taste the beer.
So we had to do a bunch
of different trips
to the Finger Lakes
and central New York.
Thankfully, Sarah did
most of the driving,
and I did most of the tasting--
which was pretty good for me.
And some of the days we
were at a brewery at noon,
and we would hit five
or six on a normal day.
We topped out at 10 one day.
SARAH ANNESE: It's
a really tough job.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Yeah.
Well, when everywhere you
go you ask for a flight,
and the tenth brewery brings
out a flight of 10 beers--
that's not what
you want, actually.
So that was a challenge,
but I think we actually
finished with a couple weekends
left at the end where we didn't
have to visit any breweries,
which I was kind of amazed
about.
I think we visited
our last breweries
in the middle of July.
SARAH ANNESE: It was
July 12th, I think.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Yeah, we
finished at Southern Tier,
in western New York.
I'm sure most of you
know Southern Tier.
And that was a great
place to finish it.
It was a lot of planning,
but it was worth it.
And because we got to
do that we surprised,
I think, some people
by actually going
to visit them in
the four months,
instead of just calling them up.
We got to really see what
the trends were in the state
and how the regions
are really different.
One of the regions that
surprised us the most
was the Adirondacks-- around
Lake Placid they don't really
seem to care very
much about what's
going on outside their bubble.
The breweries don't really
distribute very far,
and they're focused on making
classic English styles-- scotch
ales, red ales.
We had a brewer look at
us totally straight faced
and tell us that the
hop craze is just a fad.
It's gonna go away.
People will get over
it and stop using
hops so much, they'll get back
to scotch ales and brown ales,
and, you know,
they'll just get over.
That was one of
those moments where
we were kind of dumbfounded.
I mean, it's kind of great
that these people just
do what they do and
they don't care.
SARAH ANNESE: And I mean
the same line up for years.
They just never brew
anything different
and they just stick
to what they know.
There's something really
beautiful in that.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Right.
And then even this
little brewery--
Blue Line Brewing, in Saranac
Lake-- it's in an old car wash.
So they benefited from
some great drainage.
But he's kind of the
experimental brewer
in the region, almost, because
he added ginger to his red ale.
And he made a pale
ale, but it's sweet.
It's a sweet pale ale.
So it's not a American pale ale,
that by most other standards
is pretty hoppy.
It's sweet.
It's malt forwarded.
The hops are almost
not important to him.
So that for him to be kind of
the new experimental guy doing
that stuff-- compared to
other regions in the state--
it's kind of incredible
that there's this feel.
Almost all the brewers
feel this way in that area.
They've just been doing
what they're doing,
and they're going to
continue doing it.
SARAH ANNESE: So this blue
line on the right-- those two
photos-- that's the
car wash outside,
and that's his brew system.
And on the left,
those are the tab
handles at Great
Adirondack Pub and Brewery,
and the brewer
actually carves those.
So he does all this
woodwork and it feels really
like the Adirondacks.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: We saw a lot
of that, actually, upstate.
Where Brewer's-- they're brewing
and they're making everything
else in that brewery.
They are working at
the bar, and they're
making the tap handles and--
SARAH ANNESE: Making the
food for the brew pub.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Yeah,
there was one little brew pub
that we want to where
the brewer-owner,
he does everything.
He cooks.
He does the whole thing.
SARAH ANNESE: We were
sitting there talking to him,
and then he took
a break to go put
some french fries in the fryer.
And then came back
and talked to us.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: So upstate
is really different than some
of the breweries that
you might see down here.
The Hudson Valley, on the other
side, is incredibly creative.
Newburgh Brewing
kind of, we thought,
encapsulates a lot of
the range of the state.
They're making things like
English style bitters,
that are nice and sessionable.
They're making cream ales,
kind of classic styles.
On the flip side, they
make some crazy stuff.
They made this beer
called Cafe Sour,
that we had when
we were up there.
It's just kind of bizarre.
SARAH ANNESE: But delicious.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Yes.
So it's sour.
It's tart.
It's got a light body,
and it's refreshing.
But they use Ethiopian
coffee and geisha root in it.
It smells exactly like
coffee and that aromas
that you might associate
with a stout or a porter.
And then you get this really
tart beer coming after it,
and it's a little
confusing but wonderful.
So they're doing that.
And they're barrel aging and
trying out different yeasts.
Peekskill Brewery, which you
see there on the bottom left,
is really easy to visit
from here, actually.
It's right across the street
from the Peekskill train
station, and they've got
one of the first coolships
in New York state.
So they have cooled
beer in an open vessel,
after it's been brewed.
And they're brewing things
like simple sour, which
is corn and wheat based
and also really sour, tart,
refreshing-- great for
summer type of deal.
And they brew a beer
called Amazeballs, which
is like an IPA with all
the aroma and flavors
but without bitterness,
because they just didn't really
use much bittering hops at all.
So they're really
trying to find new ways
to do interesting things
and change things up.
And then they have little
guys like Sloop Brewing, which
you may have heard
recently-- they're expanding.
But they started
out in a garage,
selling a peach berliner
weisse at farmers' markets.
So the Hudson Valley
for us really kind of
showcased the wide variety
of what's out there,
the creativity--
SARAH ANNESE: Really
pushing the boundaries.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Yeah.
And then in New York City.
New York City-- I'm
sure most of you
have been to visit some
of these breweries--
but New York City has kind of
a weird brewing scene because
of the space issues and the
cost associated with being here.
So a place like Big Alice
opened on a 10 gallon system--
so probably what some of you
home brewers are brewing on.
I mean it's tiny.
You walk into the
brewery and it's
just-- it's just
there, that's it.
SARAH ANNESE: Can
we take a tour?
Yeah, sure, it's right here.
Here it is.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Yeah.
So they started on that.
They're moving to a
five barrel system soon.
They're brewing with kind
of wild, wacky things
like kumquats and
jalapenos and teas
and all kinds of
different things.
We hadn't heard of
some of them before.
So they're really kind
of changing things up.
They're taking a home
brewer's approach to beer.
Like Chris Cuzme,
which is actually
at 508 Gastrobrewery--
which is not far from here.
How many of you have been
to 508 Gastrobrewery?
Any of you?
SARAH ANNESE: It's in Tribeca.
Some people.
This is a picture of
his brewing system
on the bottom, right side.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Right.
It's a small, two
barrel homemade system.
SARAH ANNESE: It's in the
basement of this Tribeca
restaurant.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: It's jammed in
to the basement of a restaurant
that's been made into
a little brew pub.
These tiny little
breweries are what's
driving New York's growth,
to some degree right now.
And they're fitting it in.
But we're also getting some of
these mid-sized brewers that
are brewing on 15
barrel systems,
like Sam Richardson at Other
Half, who's pictured here.
He's brewing almost
exclusively west coast style
IPA's-- so the complete
opposite of the Atterondacks.
All you taste is hops
when you go in there
and when you come out of there.
SARAH ANNESE: It's good.
It's a lot of hops.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Yeah.
You can't really taste
much else after, though.
New York City is seeing
this boom, and a lot of it
is happening out in
the outer boroughs.
Finally, all of the
boroughs have a brewery.
Flagship Brewing just
opened on Staten Island.
The Bronx got Gun
Hill in February,
and Bronx Brewery is finally
going to be opening, hopefully
later this summer.
In Queens-- like Big Alice
Brewing and Transmitter Brewing
and SingleCut-- Queens
is the fastest growing
in terms of breweries.
They just keep adding them.
SARAH ANNESE: Like five or
six in the past two years,
even-- breweries.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Yeah,
so the New York City
kind of landscape of beer
is really changing a lot.
SARAH ANNESE: Now we'll
talk about the Finger Lakes.
We talk about the
Finger Lakes a lot,
because we were so surprised.
It has the largest concentration
of breweries in any region.
I mean Seneca lake alone,
there's like 10 breweries
right around it.
And a lot of the
breweries are in wineries.
And what happened was, we
talked to a lot of these owners
and they were like,
well, women were coming,
and they were bringing
their husbands.
And they were going
on wine tours,
and the husbands didn't want
to drink any of the wine.
So we opened a brewery.
On the top left side you'll
see War Horse Brewing, which
is like a theme
park of drinking,
of wine and beer and food.
There's different
areas you can go to.
There's like a pirate
themed food place.
They're opening to be like a one
stop shop of drinking and fun.
And then on the
right, this picture
is from Starkey's Lookout.
The Finger Lakes--
it's just the view.
The view is really what
makes it so amazing.
The one on the
bottom left, that's
from Two Goats Brewing,
which is also on Seneca Lake.
You're just sitting out on this
deck, drinking a fresh beer.
What could be any
better than that?
What we did find about
the Finger Lakes,
was a little weird,
was that nobody's
really doing any barrel aging.
There's such an opportunity here
for the winery slash brewery
to use the wine barrels
and age some beer.
But we didn't really
see any of that.
Although we did
see War Horse makes
a riesling ale, which is juice
from New York Riesling Grapes,
blended into the wort.
So it's contracted out,
but it was really good.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: And a lot of
those Finger Lakes breweries--
they're contract brewing.
At regional breweries in
New York State, mostly.
I think they're kind of
catching up a little bit
with-- maybe they want to
have a brewing system or not,
but they're not quite there yet.
SARAH ANNESE: So that brings
us to western New York.
On the left, that's
Community Beer Works,
which is in Buffalo.
And on the right, on the top is
Rock Brewing and on the bottom
is Rohrbach Brewing, both
of which are in Rochester.
The interesting thing
about western New York
is that they don't
really care what's
going on in New York City.
They associate way
more with Toronto.
It's closer.
They're in their
own little world of,
you know, we're gonna
make a really great beer.
And we're just gonna
have it around here.
We're not gonna send it off to
New York, or to New York City.
They're making some
really amazing beers.
And I don't know about you guys,
but we grew up on Long Island,
and we live in
New York City now.
So we kind of felt
like, we have everything
we want here in New York City.
What do we need go to
Buffalo or Rochester?
Let me tell you that
this book-- I mean
we couldn't have
been more wrong.
The beers at Community Beer
Works, they're so great.
It's just so worth the trip
to Buffalo or Rochester
just to taste some beers.
It was a really eye
opening experience for us.
So then we have
Long Island, which
is all the way on the
other side of the state.
Particularly Greenport-- this
picture on the bottom left
is of the view of
Greenport Harbor.
And Greenport is really
representative of what's
going on in Long
Island right now,
which is growth Long Island
Beer-- so many breweries are
opening, and they're
getting bigger.
Greenport just
last week opened up
an expansion in Peconic,
which will increase their beer
output to over 25,000
barrels, from just over 3,000.
So it's really a lot of
excitement and growth
going on in Long Island.
And the one thing that the
Long Island breweries are
is they're very collaborative.
So on the top left,
that's Barrier Brewing.
And Barrier kind of
made news, in a bad way.
The entire brewhouse
was destroyed
during Hurricane Sandy.
And at one point, we didn't know
if they would ever open again.
They didn't know if they
would ever open again.
But the Long Island
brewers really
kind of banned
together behind them.
Blue Point invited them all
over to do a collaboration brew,
and they raised almost
$30,000 to rebuild.
Now they opened a new
taproom a couple months ago.
There's really a lot of
collaboration and community
going on with Long Island beer.
When we got this
assignment I thought,
you know what, no big deal.
It's four months.
There's two of us.
We can do all this traveling
and all this writing
and it's not really
going to be so hard.
What was that?
Wrong.
My God, it was like a lot more
work than we even thought.
We had a couple of
challenges along the way.
We changed our editor.
Our original editor left,
and another editor came in.
And thankfully, she was as
excited about the project
as we were, so she
really pushed it through.
We had heard horror stories
about people changing
their editors and their project
just kind of like fizzling out.
This is a guidebook, so I
really wanted-- oh sorry, I
should say that a
lot of people ask us
how we split up the work.
And naturally Giancarlo loves
planning trips and traveling,
and I don't like to plan things.
I just like to go on trips.
So he did all that,
which was really great.
Just totally naturally
that kind of went to him.
And since I have a
background in journalism,
I sort of took over
making the book cohesive.
While we both wrote
pretty much equally--
it's split up into
different sections
for each brewery,
brewpub, and bar.
So we wrote about half and
half but I took it upon myself
to make sure the book
had a cohesive voice.
Because it is a guidebook, and
because people could write it
off as, oh, I'll just
find that on the internet,
I really wanted it to
have a personality.
I really wanted people
to feel the enthusiasm
and the excitement that we
had when we were visiting all
these places and
to inspire people
to go visit their tiny little
brewery in the Adirondacks
or in the Finger Lakes.
And just see it see what
regional beer in New York
tastes like, because we
do live in New York City
and it's easy to just feel like
we can get whatever we want.
So yeah, that's what I hope to
infuse-- this beautiful feeling
that we had about New
York beer in this book.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: We're
originally from Long Island.
We live in New York.
So we do feel a
connection to our state.
But heading upstate
and exploring
all these different
areas, we really
got to know the
state so much better.
And breweries are a great
way to learn a place,
and know what people
are like, and talk
to people at the
brewery or the brewers
and see what it's
like where they live.
SARAH ANNESE: You really get
like a cross section of locals
sitting at the bar when
you're at a brewery.
You talk to some of
them, and you kind of
get a feel of what
this area is like.
Are people really coming to
this one brewery every week,
or are they going to a lot
of different breweries?
Or are they going
to a bar instead?
It's a really interesting way to
learn about a city or a region.
And this kind of
project-- the fact
that the New York
beer writing community
is so supportive and so
amazing-- we couldn't have
done it without
our fellow authors.
Particularly John Holl, who
wrote the American Craft Beer
Cookbook, and Josh
Bernstein, who
wrote the Complete Beer Course.
This is our first book, so we
were in totally new territory.
And these guys really
took us under their wings
and just were so generous
with advice and information.
Look out for this, or
make sure about this.
So we did have a lot of
help, also from Seamless,
because we never would have
made it through that last week
if we didn't have
food delivered.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: We were
pretty much just hunkered down,
writing.
SARAH ANNESE: Holed
up in our apartment.
GIANCARLO ANNESE:
Now that we've gone
through this whole
experience, and we
traveled all over the state,
we met all these people,
we drank a lot of beer--
we think New York State has
a really special place in what's
happening in beer right now.
The country in general
is excited about beer.
There are new breweries
opening almost every day,
it seems like,
across the country.
But New York in
particular-- I think partly
because of its brewing history
and its agricultural industry
and where it's headed-- really
has a special place in that.
When we started, there were
130 breweries last year.
Now there's 165.
It's a $2.2 billion
industry in this state
alone, which Governor
Cuomo is pushing for.
He's realized there's
a lot of money
here, so he's
really going for it.
And he's changing
some of the laws.
Whatever you think about
other things he's doing,
he's really helped brewers
out-- with the Farm Brewery
Law and the new Craft Act.
So he has been-- and
the state in general
has been really
supportive of brewers
and changing laws and
trying to help them.
So especially with something
like the Farm Brewery Law--
it's one of the
things that we think
will make New York different
and unique from other states
where beer is an
agricultural product.
When it comes down to it, you've
got grain and hops and yeast.
Water isn't agricultural, but
the grain and the hops are.
By having fresh,
local ingredients
you can give beer
a different taste
that you can't get elsewhere.
You won't be able to get New
York hops, really, elsewhere
when New York brewers
are using those hops.
And we're seeing hop farms
pop up around the state,
kind of reclaiming that history
of being a major producer.
Cornell Cooperative Extension
is helping them out with that,
and helping them get
set up, and figure out
what they need to do.
So there's a real push for that.
And there is a kind of fledgling
but growing grain supply
in the state.
No maltsters yet, but they're
apparently on the way.
I think that will give the state
a different identity than it
has had and that
other states have.
And on top of that,
there are some breweries
growing their own ingredients.
Ithaca is working
towards brewing a state
beer with their own barley,
and they've got hops growing.
Hopshire Farm Brewery, just
down the road from them,
is growing their own hops.
Ommegang, pictured
here on the left,
is also talking
about growing hops.
So there's a lot of
push towards making
this a local ingredient that
is specific to New York,
that you can't get elsewhere.
And then on the
other side of things,
just in terms of the
opening of breweries,
New York City is finally
having its explosion
of breweries that I think
everyone has been waiting for.
Until a few years
ago, we had a couple.
Compared to the
number of people here,
it was kind of staggering
how few breweries we had.
And now a little place like
Rockaway Brewing Company--
which is oddly in Long Island
City, down in the bottom right,
it's tiny-- but they
opened a couple years ago.
Queens has seen the explosion.
The Outer Boroughs
are seeing it.
And we're getting specialized
brewers like Other Half brewing
west coast IPA's, and
Transmitter Brewing,
in Long Island City,
brewing farmhouse styles.
And there are things
that you can do now
that you just
couldn't do before.
Recently, there was a day
in Long Island City where
you could walk one mile
and visit three breweries.
A little over a mile--
visit three breweries.
That's something that just
you couldn't do before.
You pretty much had Brooklyn and
Chelsea, which is now closed.
They are a brewpub.
They're still brewing,
but it's really
changed in terms of
taprooms you can visit.
Local beer is out and around
town at bars and restaurants.
So that has really
changed and is
pushing things in a different
direction and making New York
a better place to drink beer.
SARAH ANNESE: Exactly.
Until recently, people didn't
really think about New York
when they thought about
great beer states.
You think about
great beer cities
even-- Portland and
Asheville-- those are really
what people think of when
they think beer cities.
And we hope that New York
can finally be on that map.
We think it should be.
We think New York is kind of
an unsung beer destination--
the whole state.
And we really hope to
inspire more and more people
to visit New York breweries.
So that about wraps
it up for our talk.
I don't know if you
want do some Q&A. Great.
AUDIENCE: So I'll
start with a question.
Do you see any common
trends in the people
that are opening up
these new breweries?
SARAH ANNESE: So there's kind
of like a couple different sides
to that.
A lot of brewers who are going
professional were home brewers.
I would say it's about
half and half home brewers,
and the other half
would be brewers
who have trained
at other breweries.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Right.
A lot of the brewers who are
starting these really tiny
breweries are home brewers who
have just kind of scaled up
a little bit.
Some of them are brewing
out of their garages.
There's actually a
surprising number that are.
And they're brewing
on a couple barrels.
But then there are
some mid-size brewers
that are opening
with brewers that
have been brewing for a long
time-- like Other Half, Sam
Richardson or
Newburgh's, Chris Basso.
They've been in the
brewing industry
for I think at least
10 years, each of them.
So that is starting
to happen as well.
You've got small
guys, and you've
got some of the brewers who have
been at places like Brooklyn
Brewery kind of graduating
out and starting their own.
SARAH ANNESE:
Barrier was started
by two guys who
worked at Sixpoint.
It's an interesting
trend, that's
going two different ways.
AUDIENCE: So I wasn't familiar
with that Farm Brewery
law you mentioned, but I looked
it up while you were talking.
So you have to use a certain
amount of New York sourced
ingredients in your beer,
which starts at like 20%,
but then in a few
years increases
to 60%, then eventually 90%.
I'm surprised to see that
even included like hops.
These are things that I really
associate with like Pacific
Northwest, for the
great hops or whatever.
Are you seeing also a
corresponding explosion
in producers of some
of these ingredients?
And is the quality up to snuff?
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Yeah,
especially with hops.
People are getting
excited about hops.
Some of these farmers
are looking at it
as a good way to-- because
hops are popular and expensive
you can make a good
profit margin on then
if you can sell them.
The problem is, there isn't
really the infrastructure here
that there used to be.
And the climate is actually
a little bit different.
It's not as ideal as
the Pacific Northwest
for some of the
varieties, but they're
looking to find which
varieties work best.
And so I think we're in a
little bit of that time frame,
in terms of hops,
where they're still
figuring out what works best.
And we'll see.
There's going to be more,
especially in the short term.
There's going to be things like
wet hop beers more in New York
than there have been.
Greenport opened
their new brewery.
It's literally down the
road from the hop farm.
And so they can
go get the hops--
SARAH ANNESE: It's
like a hundred feet
away from the farm--
you're really close.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Things
like that are showing up,
but at the same time the
hop production isn't there
to support the
year-round production.
SARAH ANNESE: And
especially because hops
are such a small
ingredient by weight.
The 20% is 20% percent
of ingredients by weight,
aside from water.
So there needs to be
other things besides hops.
And a lot of the
brewers, I think
they are a little concerned
as to the percentages,
because the agricultural
aspect of it
hasn't met the
brewing aspect of it.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: There are a
couple maltsters opening up,
and there's some
grain being grown.
We've heard a good
amount about rye
being grown in the state--
not really as much barley.
SARAH ANNESE:
Previously it would
have to leave the
state to go get malted.
GIANCARLO ANNESE:
Right, it still does.
SARAH ANNESE: Right.
So until these
maltsters open, it's
kind of defeating the purpose
of getting the New York grain,
because it has to go get malted
elsewhere and then come back.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: It
supports the farm,
but it's a little bit weird
that the closest place it can go
is Massachusetts
to go get malted.
So the other thing
some brewers are
doing to get in under
the Farm Brewery laws--
they're using other ingredients.
One of the most popular ones
we're seeing is New York honey.
They'll make a beer
that use a lot honey,
and then they'll make their 20%.
Almost nobody can go out
there and just brew an IPA
and hit their 20%.
Right now it's not happening,
to be a year round beer
type of thing.
AUDIENCE: Have you seen
differences in distribution
regionally within
New York State?
I'm asking you this, because
I spent a while on the Finger
Lakes and literally was
unaware that there were
any other breweries there,
besides like Ithaca.
And yet, I come to New York,
and it's really obvious
that there's all these local
breweries that are distributing
at least within their
area and possibly farther.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Right,
so one of the things
we found in the Finger
Lakes, particularly--
these winery-breweries--
they're pretty much just serving
their beer at
their tasting room.
SARAH ANNESE: They're
basically brew pubs.
GIANCARLO ANNESE:
Yeah, in a way.
They're not the traditional
brewpub you might think of,
but they're pretty much
just serving on premises.
SARAH ANNESE: We operated
on the definition of brewpub
meaning they didn't distribute.
So a brewery that did
distribute was a brewery,
but a brewery that didn't
distribute it and had food
was a brewpub.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: Right.
And so like Ithaca and some
other breweries in the region--
they're distributing.
There's a tiny one that's
a farm brewery called
Good Nature in Hamilton.
So there are some that are
small and distributing,
but a lot of
breweries-- they're not.
Or they're self-distributing
in a ten mile radius.
SARAH ANNESE: Yeah, just to
like the bars around them.
GIANCARLO ANNESE:
So a lot of them,
you'll never see
unless you go there.
AUDIENCE: So there are lots of
great new breweries opening up,
but I understand there are
also some that haven't made it
and are closing down.
So my question is, what makes
a brewery have the greatest
chance of success?
What is the sort of secret sauce
that the ones who've grown up
have really had, from
what you've seen?
Is it just making great
beer or is it also
about the distribution and the
ingredients and the equipments
and so on?
SARAH ANNESE: Well,
I think it definitely
starts with making
really good beer.
But we all know of some
breweries that aren't really
making great beer but
still kind of hang around.
But I think also, on
top of having good beer,
you really need at
least a local following.
I mean, people who are going
in to get their growler
fills every week.
And we saw that, mostly,
across the board.
GIANCARLO ANNESE: I think
that a lot of breweries
have-- because it's a
localized kind of movement--
New York breweries have been
pretty successful at staying
open, because they don't
over stretch themselves.
And they first make
sure that they've
got a good imprint
in their local area.
And they try to make
themselves the local beer.
So they've got a
small distribution,
but they're selling
all their beer.
And their beer is
fresh and tastes good.
And that's something
that we're seeing more.
Brewers are not going
immediately to distributor.
They're self distributing,
while they can.
And then after they've
established a following,
they go to a distributor
who is obviously
going to take them
to a larger audience.
But it's a difficult
thing to manage--
giving your beer to
somebody else-- letting
them kind of decided
where it's going,
and how it's being stored,
and all that stuff.
So that's kind of
the progression
that we see almost
everywhere, now.
AUDIENCE: What are some of the
smallest breweries that you
guys considered or wrote about?
SARAH ANNESE: Big Alice brewing
I think was the smallest.
Oh, wait a minute--
Bridge and Tunnel is--
GIANCARLO ANNESE: No,
Bridge and Tunnel is larger.
Big Alice was
probably the smallest.
They were brewing
10 gallon batches.
Cave Mountain is really tiny.
They're brewing half
a barrel at a time.
Well, we visited them.
SARAH ANNESE: Oh,
they are in the book.
There's another one
that we didn't--
GIANCARLO ANNESE: There's
a few really tiny ones
that we visited that were
kind of-- they were OK
but they were finding
their way, still.
And there's some
brewers that will get it
after a little while.
SARAH ANNESE: But
definitely Big Alice
was the smallest actual brewer.
There were small brewpubs,
but Big Alice is the smallest.
AUDIENCE: Great,
well, I'll say thanks
very much for coming to visit.
If anyone bought
the book, these guys
are going to do signing
here afterwards.
But yeah, thanks
again for coming.
This was really fascinating.
I look forward to
reading the book.
SARAH ANNESE: Yeah,
thanks so much.
This was great.
Enjoy your book.
[APPLAUSE]